what will be knew about this macbook pro
sure I mean like you said it's going to
be the most significant macbook pro
overhaul since they release the first
retina model the higher resolution model
back in 2012 so this one's going to be a
little bit thinner a bit an error or
smaller / also easier carry it's going
to have new USBC port switch allows you
to use a single port to do charging
connect the screens transfer data to
phones it's going to have new features
like an oled key display so instead of
the standard function keys with like
volume audio controls and such you'll be
able to have a digital screen so the
different function keys will change
based on what you're doing so if you're
in itunes for example you'll see music
controls but if you're working on a word
document you might see cut copy and
paste so it's really going to adapt to
the user that sounds like fun why is it
particularly important now it does feel
like a while since we've had a macbook
refresh right so back in 2010 when Steve
Jobs introduced the ipad he called it
the future of the computer the future of
laptops a laptop replacement you know
after a couple years sales really you
know shot up but they peaked at the end
of 2013 into 2014 now sales have been
slowing the last two quarters apple
sales numbers overall have also slid so
this macbook pro update comes at a time
where Apple needs to rely on a product
that has been surprisingly resilient the
Mac even with the iPad has still been
selling between the high 3s and low
fives in terms of millions a quarter so
this product has been resilient and now
apples giving it a lot of attention with
this new upgrade so mark this is all
pretty exciting if you're a consumer how
much does this matter for investors it
does a lot because if these sales
numbers go up it's critical to investors
because the ipad is considered by a lot
of investors and industry watchers to be
key to apples bottom line but a
little-known secret is that macs and
ipads are nearly the same in terms of
how much revenue it brings Apple
especially in the last quarter that out
will reported a couple of weeks ago so
while iPad
old about twice as many units as max
their revenue was pretty much within two
or three million dollars apart from each
other so you know it's pretty
significant just quickly tell us what's
coming this fall well this fall you can
expect a new iphone as we reported
earlier it's going to look about the
same as the current models it's going to
lack a headphone jack a few design
tweaks but a much improved camera system
in a reengineered home button that
responds to a user's pressure when they
click it and this macbook also is likely
to come out at the fall we're told that
Apple is currently planning just subject
to change an event for Wednesday
September 7th to introduce the new
iPhone but it doesn't sound like this
new map the pro is going to be ready to
go at that introduction event but we'll
see what Apple ends up deciding to what
to do as we get closer